after the fall of Saigon in 1975 more
than a million desperate people fled
Vietnam many of them in small boats the
refugees were called boat people now a
successful attorney Vietnamese immigrant
Lauren moon was one of them she's
accomplished so much in the four decades
since then but one goal remained elusive
finding and thinking the men who rescued
her at sea Don Dahler has the story from
maritime college what made you want to
take this journey to begin with to try
to find these people at every big
juncture in my life
graduation law school taking the oath
having children seeing my parents I in
the back of my head I would always think
you know I have to find these I have to
find these men Lauren Vaughn carried
that passion for decades to express her
gratitude to those who saved her life
my very courageous fearless mother of
mine and she wasn't alone
I would ask my mom periodically do you
ever think about them and she would say
every time I have something good to eat
I think of them when we first arrived in
America my first thought was how could I
find the people who save us all these
years later and it's still that
important to you that's my dream boom
never gave up her mother's dream her
parents upper-class landowners in the
South faced terrible persecution once
the victorious North Vietnamese took
control under communist rule Vaughn's
father was taken to a Vietcong
re-education camp when we saw our
husband you know working and with like a
1 bowl of rice a day and there's no
that's when I thought we got to get out
I have to get him out you afraid he
would die for su a hundred percent and
that led to a daring decision to get her
entire family to flee the country along
with dozens of other families they
crammed onto a small fishing vessel and
set out to the open sea Vung was only
seven years old I'm
were just throwing up just throwing up
so much that I didn't think there was
anything left to throw up and there was
nowhere to go to the bathroom if you had
to go you just go so you're living in
all of that you're living in that for
how long we're the on at sea for ten
days did you think you were going to die
yes yes I don't know that a
seven-year-old really knows what death
is but I didn't see how we could keep
keep doing and feeling the things that
we were feeling and continue but somehow
they endured about a hundred and twenty
ships were on the same route but never
slowed then on June 29th 1980 they
watched with awe as one paused and
approached a liquefied natural gas
tanker called the Virgo there was the
smell of all kinds of things in the boat
Dan Hanson and Ken Nelson were the first
two men Vung remembers seeing I believe
I threw my shoes and stuff over the side
when we came back up aboard the main
deck because the conditions were that
bad there was no way that we were going
to let those people go away on their
boat that would have been likely
condemning them to death well the two
men came on board and then next thing I
know my mom was laughing she was crying
all at the same time and she says to me
we're going to live we're going to live
you saved your family at that point he
knew you knew your family was gonna be
okay yes the rescue meant not just
survival but set bungs family on a path
full of promise here in America 27 years
ago lauren began her journey to find
these men she researched maritime
registries scoured the internet which
led to conversations with officers
photographs and eventually an emotional
reunion
this was the first time they'd seen each
other in 37 years
dan stood on the gangway and Ken stood
on our boat and they had to lift each
child time the swells and then hand the
child over and so I I said to them that
I was delivered by you that day it was
incredible
I still feel like this is all a dream
boom got to share that special day with
her parents siblings husband and
children do you feel more American or do
you still feel Vietnamese or is there in
you no distinction this is who you are
I'll never not be Vietnamese because
that's my heritage I can't help being
American because it's my country and
when I see that - Vietnamese American I
don't see it as a dividing factor I see
it as a bridge that - is a bridge of
where I was who I was with Who I am now
and where I am today a bridge that owes
its existence to a boat and its crew who
did the most American of things
embracing the huddled masses yearning to
be free for CBS this morning Saturday
Don Dahler New York wow what a story I
mean the beacon of America shines so
brightly in the minds of immigrants who
have I mean my family has a story like
that
so countless numbers of families have
stories of both America really welcoming
them to their I love with Lauren's
mother said every time I have something
good to eat I think of them yeah I mean
what is the beautiful story yeah